do you think that's a typical Hollywood
thing to put the cart before the horse
have a thing and say oh yeah we're doing
this and we have this person attached
yeah thnkx on us yes and I don't like
pina mm-hmm I hope your Bay Area roots
sorry very sorry yeah I can say that
because I'm from the air see why are you
gonna call me out like sorry I'm for the
variance is I see that a lot though and
I think that that's that's where
Hollywood gets that bad name is that oh
yeah we're doing this and doing that and
then and then nothing yeah people like
to talk yeah what and yeah and really
believe people like to talk and I don't
know I've just made it a goal not to be
like that so when you know that you have
something in the works you kind of keep
it under wraps a little bit yes suit
yourself mmm have it on the to do list
yeah it's like that whole thing of like
don't tell God your plans kind of thing
no oh right or else you're gonna be this
point in fujian why right yes mitra spin
i think is it the other senses sounds a
good I like that it's a variational just
ended i also bought a frame from etsy
that have that numbs but yeah it may be
it is my past experience that if i've
gotten too excited another project or
did put the horse before the program
whatever i'm full of horse cart flowers
yes then i have been burned just
whatever cosmically it just happened
that way and so you know I'm a little
older a little more experience and so I
I'm a little more reserved I want to
make sure things are good in order for
acting you do that are you ready the
first one on facebook with the same just
wow just ASIS audition know if I loathe
and despise that i will say that without
a flinch I hate it when people do that
with such a fiery passion it's just so
part of it is and there's a multiple
thing obviously from my own personal
dislike but then there's also I I have
very little faith in anything
I've ever done so I walk out of the real
nap oh yeah he knows he's like heck it
was funny the first thing he said when
he saw me a couple nice guys like I
don't have time for your insecurities
right now I have to can I on pack first
as soon as I wall gather my forget it
ever happened and when I work on
projects I I tell very very few people
some of the things I get excited about
because of I think I feel like yeah it's
mean it's from my upbringing my mom or
something but I say too many things that
I'm excited or happy about and then all
these people will hear it and they don't
like that and then I feel like there's
like going to be a negative energy
that's going to just throw it to the
ground so I'll tell certain people who I
know have nothing but the best of
intentions and hopes for me you know so
I worked on something I'm not gonna
again another explain but I told chat I
was really excited about it he's like
one of the three people I've told
because I'm hoping that it comes out the
way it should cuz I know Chad's not
gonna be like oh really screw you you
know so I definitely keep things under
the wraps unless you know it's very
insignificant but if it's meaningful to
me I will not talk about it until it's
done and it comes out and that's your
your rule as well yeah let's go there's
a lot of haters out there there is a lot
of haters out there that's to say like
to bring you down well also into I get
superstitious I can't tell you how many
times I told ya join me that's gonna
happen and then the rugs pulled out so I
just know I play by the same I find it's
easier if you don't set up expectations
for other people then you have to answer
for yourself or explain yourself a lot
less yeah that's really what it is I
know a couple friends who they wouldn't
out about things and opportunities
coming up that were big big big maybes
and then they tell hundred people and
then when it invariably doesn't happen
then you have to explain a hundred times
why it didn't and each time it's gotta
suck worse than the one before so I just
avoid all that so if you know there's a
hater in your life maybe someone close
to you maybe not what do you do have you
treated just you you know that whatever
you tell them they're going to be the
doubting Thomas
keep my mouth closed the entire time I
just don't well first personally I'd try
to keep those people out of my close
circle of communication link honestly if
someone gonna be bad negative to me I've
gotten to the point in my life that I
have a lot of friends you're gonna be
really crappy I kind of don't need you
around so I try to surround myself with
supportive people but then yeah it's not
so much what I was saying that I keep
things under wraps because of negative
energy its people intend to do it they
don't seek out saying I wish you bad
it's just when they hear they say
there's just inherent jealousy sometimes
sure so I try to avoid personally those
obviously negative nancies ER however
the terms that you put it was Oh
doubting Thomas doubting Thomas I like
that so um I don't know about you Jed
well there's a there's that too for me
but a little bit too is like if you say
something too early it's almost as if
the excitement of whatever it is might
just it sometimes kills my excitement
you know in leading up to it I don't
want to be like hey I'm writing season
two and I'm like oh that's great that's
exciting and I'm like huh it's nothing
exciting so you know I could that makes
probably no sense but I just say it's
like it's it's also one aspect of it
it's like you find makes total sense you
fire it off all the energy to do it in
talking about doing it and then it's
like it kind of don't feel like reading
it anymore actually I'd like the idea of
writing it just don't feeling doing it
now xenophon controlling baby
you